[Music]
mood changes
morning sickness and a slow
painful death
that's what pregnancy would look like
for a man
but
how could men
even get pregnant
why would a pregnancy be so dangerous
for them
and
how would society change if any person
on earth could get pregnant
this is what if and here's what would
happen if men could get pregnant
maybe you've seen junior arnold
schwarzenegger aka the mominator has an
embryo implanted in his abdominal cavity
with hormone therapy and surgical labor
he carries a baby to term monador
well this is not what would happen in
reality
regardless of your gender if you don't
have a uterus or if you attempt to carry
a pregnancy outside your uterus
it would be a dangerous situation
both for you and your baby
this is known as an extra uterine or
ectopic pregnancy
it's a life-threatening scenario that
occurs in one out of every 100
pregnancies
usually it's when a fertilized egg
attaches itself to the fallopian tube
but today we're going to see what would
happen if you could become pregnant just
like arnold
hasta la vista baby
first you need to have a fertilized egg
implanted in your body
like in junior the abdominal cavity
could be a good candidate
if implanted at the right moment of
development the embryo could attach
itself to any living tissue it finds
this could be your kidney liver
even spleen
if there's enough placental formation
the fetus could develop and you could
carry it for nine months
this happened to a south african woman
and her baby in 2003
the embryo developed in the woman's
liver
and after a complex operation this
miracle baby was born
weighing 2.8 kilograms
this was a rare success considering that
one in 200 extra uterine pregnancies are
deadly for the mother
the biggest issue here is detachment in
a typical pregnancy the endometrium or
specialized lining of the uterus
completely detaches when giving birth
if you carried a pregnancy in your
abdomen
this kind of detachment wouldn't be
possible
it would require some very challenging
surgery to remove the placental material
the biggest risk would be suffering an
injury that could cause internal
bleeding
even then the embryo itself could damage
whichever organ it was attached to
this could lead to spontaneous
hemorrhaging and death
maybe it would be safer if you could
have a uterus transplanted into your
body
but this would be incredibly complicated
transplants in general are complicated
your immune system could reject the new
body part
plus if your body has never had a uterus
you'd need to make sure it receives a
natural blood supply to carry a baby
yeah you'd need to divert arteries and
veins to send blood to this new organ
so
with one major surgery to get a uterus
and another to deliver the baby
there would be a lot of risks
and even though it could be possible
it's never been done
but according to some medical experts
this could happen in the near future
of course these scenarios don't mean
that anyone could just become pregnant
it would require a lot of decisions and
operations
but here let's get hypothetical
without limits to who could become
pregnant the world would look a lot
different if men who statistically
dominate business and political
professions could get pregnant
well abortions could become legal or
more readily available in more places
paid leave for pregnancies would
probably become more commonplace too
family planning would dramatically
change
couples could take turns bearing
children depending on where they are
physically mentally or in their careers
it could lead to more diverse and safer
types of birth control
if anyone could get pregnant
developing effective contraceptives
would be important
otherwise the population could rise even
faster
and last but certainly not least
this could all lead to more empathy
regarding pregnancy birth and parental
leave
[Music]
while men may be biologically unable to
carry a pregnancy today
anything could be possible in the future
like growing babies in artificial wombs
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]